量子情報と計算の理解へようこそ。私はJohn Matusで、IBMの教育担当テクニカルディレクターだ。
Quantum。これはシリーズの第12回目のレッスンで、第3ユニット最後のレッスンだ。第3ユニットは量子情報の一般的な
定式化について扱っている。このレッスンは量子情報における基本的な概念を中心に展開する。その概念とは
量子状態の精製（purification）だ。ある密度行列で表された量子状態の精製とは
より大きな複合系の純粋状態であり、複合系の残りの部分を
捨てるか、あるいはトレースアウトすると元の状態が得られるものだ。すべての密度行列には精製が存在し、精製を研究することで
量子状態や量子情報全般について多くのことを学べる。直感的なレベルでは
純粋状態を表す量子状態ベクトルは密度行列よりも単純な数学的対象だ。そして
状態の精製を考えることで、系の任意の量子状態をより大きいが
単純な何かの一部として捉えることができる。また、2つの量子状態間のFidelityについても話す。Fidelityとは両者の
類似性や重なりを定量化する値だ。特定の状態がある基準と比べてどれほど良いかを測る方法としてよく使われる。
理想的な状態と比較するためだ。特にFidelityの定義といくつかの基本的な性質について説明し、
Fidelityがどのようにpurificationとつながるかを見ていく。レッスンの概要を示そう。まずpurificationから始め、
定義と、必要な場合に求め方を教えてくれる存在の簡単な証明を扱う。次に
2つの系の量子状態ベクトルのSchmidt分解について説明し、Schmidt分解が
purificationとどう関連するかを見ていく。次に、同じ状態の任意の2つのpurification間の非常に重要な関係について説明する。これはユニタリー
等価性（unitary equivalence of purifications）として知られている。最後にいくつかの例を見ていく。そしてFidelityに移り、
その定義といくつかの基本的な性質を扱う。Fidelityを測定と結びつける非常に
便利な事実である緩やかな測定補題（gentle measurement lemma）についても話す。そして最後にUhlmannの定理に移り、
FidelityとpurificationをつなぐFidelityの基本的な関係を確立する。では
purificationの定義から始めよう。密度行列で表されるとする状態のpurificationとは
より大きな複合系の純粋状態であり、残りの部分をトレースアウトすると最初に始めた元の状態が得られるものだ。
これを数学的な言葉でより正確に表現できる。
系Xがある状態rowにあるとしよう。つまりrowはXの状態を表す密度行列だ。
そしてSは系XYのペアの量子状態ベクトルで、純粋状態からyをトレースアウトすると
rowが残るとき、Sはrowのpurificationであるというわけだ。もちろん名前は重要ではない。
系や状態は何と名付けてもいいし、系の順序も重要ではない。例えば
系yが右ではなく左にあっても、それ以外が同じなら、SΨはrowのpurificationと呼ばれる。ただし
簡単のため、レッスンの残りではこの設定を主に使うことにする。最初に言っておくべきことは
purificationは常に存在する、つまりすべての密度行列rowについてということだ。より正確に言えば、すべての密度
行列rowには定義で説明したようなpurificationが存在する。ただし系yがXと少なくとも同じ大きさであれば、
つまりyがXと少なくとも同じ数の古典的な状態を持てばよい。purificationの概念と
purificationが常に存在するという事実は非常に重要であり、量子情報を美しくしている要素でもある。レッスンの最後までにそれを
納得してもらえると思う。では、すべての密度行列がpurificationを持つことを証明しよう。その過程で
必要なときにpurificationを求める方法も分かる。定義と同様に
Xを系として、rowをXの状態を表す密度行列とする。
次に、rowを純粋状態の凸結合として表す任意の表現を考える。画面に書かれた言葉の通り、
正整数nのある選択に対して、確率ベクトルp_0からp_、および量子
状態ベクトルψ_0からψ_があり、確率で重み付けされた対応する純粋状態を平均すると
rowが得られる。例えばスペクトル定理を使ってrowのこのような表現を得ることができる。その場合
nをXの古典的な状態の数にできる。実際にはnをrowのランクにできる。これは
rowの非ゼロの固有値の数に等しく、各固有値をその多重度の回数だけ数えたものだ。
これはXの古典的な状態の数より大きくなることはないが、小さくなることはある。一方で
rowのスペクトル分解である必要はなく、これらの量子状態ベクトルが直交している必要もない。例えばrowのこのような表現は
何でも構わない。そしてこれがrowのpurificationだ。和の範囲は
rowの表現と同じ値にわたり、和の中では確率の平方根をF_Aとテンソル積した
k_aを掛ける。ここで0からn-1は第2の系yの古典的な状態であると仮定しているため、
定義と同様にSがXYのペアの量子状態ベクトルであることは理にかなっている。この表現において
yの標準基底状態を使う必要は実はない。代わりに直交規格化された状態の任意のコレクションを
k_0からk_の代わりに使うこともできる。これが確かにpurificationであることをyに対する部分トレースを計算することで確認できる。
部分トレースを実行して得られる状態の表現はここにある。
k_aのbraのBのトレースはaがBに等しいかどうかで1か0になる。そのため表現は
rowの元の表現に簡略化される。簡単なことだ。よってpurificationを見つけるのは非常に簡単で、
yの古典的な状態が十分にあるか、あるいは代わりに使える十分に大きな直交規格化集合があればよい。
標準基底状態ket_0からket_の代わりに使う場合だ。ちなみに
yの古典的な状態の数がrowのランクより小さい場合、purificationは存在しない。それについては
必要であれば考えてみてほしい。例を見てみよう。
密度行列のレッスンで何度か見た密度行列を考えよう。この密度行列を
純粋状態の凸結合として表す表現がある。スペクトル分解ではないが、
それは問題ない。そしてほぼ労力なしで、
このレシピに従うことで状態のpurificationを書き下せる。これがこの密度行列の唯一のpurificationではない。purificationは一意ではないが、それで構わない。
この定義は一意性については何も述べていない。実際、同じ状態の異なるpurificationの間には非常に興味深い関係があるが、
それについてはレッスンの後半で少し議論する。次にSchmidt分解を考える。これは
二部量子状態ベクトルをある特定の形式で表したものだ。その形式についてはすぐ説明する。Erhard
Schmidtにちなんで名付けられたもので、Graham-Schmidt直交化手続きで知られているSchmidtと同一人物だが、Schmidt分解という名前は本来付けるべきでは
なかったかもしれない。数学的には行列の特異値分解と呼ばれるものと等価であり、これは
実際に複数回独立に再発見されたが、そういうことは時々起こる。ともかく、ここで意味することを述べる。
Schmidt分解とは、システムXYのペアに対する量子状態ベクトルsの任意の選択において
、sを常に特定の形式で書くことができるということだ。その形式は画面に
示されているとおりで、Rは正の整数、p_0からp_は正の実数であり、
合わせて確率ベクトルを構成する。x_0からx_はシステムXに対応する単位ベクトルで、y_0
からy_はシステムYに対応する単位ベクトルだ。一見してそれほど特別には見えないかもしれないが、
x_0からx_とy_0からy_の両方の集合が
正規直交でなければならないと聞けば話が変わる。なぜそれが特別なのかというと、二つの基底の一方に任意の基底を選んだとして、例えば
システムXに対応するXベクトルを選んだとすると、sをこの形式で常に表現できるが、それによってYベクトルの
選び方が特定の方法に強制される。実際、標準基底を扱うときのように、標準基底測定を
分析する際にはごく普通にこれを行う。しかし一般には、Xベクトルとして正規直交基底を選んでも、
得られるYベクトルが必ずしも正規直交になるとは限らない。同様に、
Yベクトルとして正規直交基底を選んでsをその形式で表そうとしても可能だが、今度はXベクトルが
必ずしも正規直交にならない。さらに、両方のシステムに対して正規直交ベクトルを選んで
この形式でsを表そうとしても、交差項が必要になる場合があるためうまくいかない。だがこの和には
インデックスが一つしかない（aのみ）。だからこの形式は特別なのだが、それでも常に
与えられた単位ベクトルsをこの形式で書くことは可能だ。やり方はこうだ。まずスペクトル分解を計算する。
二つのシステムのどちらかの縮約状態についてのスペクトル分解だ。どちらでも構わないが、説明のためにXの縮約状態を見てみよう。
Yをトレースアウトするわけで、つまりp_0からp_は
この縮約状態rowの固有値であり、x_0からx_はこれらの固有値に対応する単位固有ベクトルだ。
なお、固有値がゼロの項は無視するという前提だ。そういった項は和に何も寄与しないからだ。
つまりp_0からp_はすべて正の実数であり、Rはゼロでない
固有値の数（重複度を含む）であり、rowのランクに等しい。これでp_0からp_
マイナス1、およびx_0からx_が得られた。残るのはy_0からy_
のベクトルを求めることだ。うまくいく選択肢は一つしかない。これらのベクトルはこの時点で一意に決まっており、
画面に示されている簡単な公式を使えば容易に求められる。ここで驚くべきことは、
このようにこれらのベクトルを定義すれば、それらが正規直交であることが保証されるということだ。これによってSchmidt分解が得られる。このことは本
動画では証明しないが、それほど難しくない。興味があれば、レッスンの文書教材を参照してほしい。
リンクはいつも通り動画の説明欄に記載してある。例として、この
量子状態ベクトルを考えてみよう。これは繰り返し取り上げている密度行列の例のpurificationとして得たものだ。
ゼロ状態とプラス状態が正規直交でないため、これはSchmidt分解ではないが、
今説明した手順を使えばSchmidt分解を求めることができる。最初のステップはX系の縮約
状態のスペクトル分解を計算することだ。これは同じ密度行列の例であり、レッスン9で
見たスペクトル分解がある。そこでp_0、P_1、x_0、X_1を画面に
示されているように選ぶ。p_0とP_1はrowの固有値であり、x_0とX_1は
対応する単位固有ベクトルだ。残るはy_0とy_1の計算だが、これを行うとket +
がy_0となり、-1 * ket -がy_1となる。すぐにはわからないかもしれないが、
実際に計算してみるとそうなる。そして予想どおり、計算が正しければこの二つのベクトルは正規直交になる。
これでSchmidt分解が
得られた。Schmidt分解は多くの場面で非常に便利で、まもなくpurificationについて何を教えてくれるかが分かる。
purificationは一意ではない。密度行列で表された与えられた量子状態は、実際に無限に多くのpurificationを持つ。しかし
同じ状態の任意の二つのpurificationの間には常に成り立つ密接な関係がある。これはしばしばpurificationの
ユニタリ同値性と呼ばれる。仕組みはこうだ。rowをシステムXの量子状態を表す密度行列とする。
そして同じ複合システムの純粋状態であるその状態の任意の二つのpurificationがあるとする。
具体的に述べると、sとfiが
システムXYのペアの量子状態ベクトルであり、システムYをトレースアウトするとどちらもrowを与える
とする。purificationのユニタリ同値性が言うのは、システムY上のみで作用するユニタリ操作Uが存在し、
そのUがsをfiに変換するということだ。つまり、これらが
rowの任意のpurificationであり、どちらもrowをpurifyし、
同じ複合システムXYの状態であるということ以外何も仮定しなくても、
両者はY上のユニタリ操作の意味でなんらかの意味で同値でなければならない。
これがなぜ興味深いのか、どんな含意があるのかを示す例をいくつか見る。しかしまず、
なぜそれが成り立つのかを見てみよう。rowのスペクトル分解から始めよう。rowは
sとfiの両方がpurifyする密度行列だ。Schmidt分解を議論したときと同様に、
ゼロ固有値に対応する項はすべて除外してあると仮定する。つまりp_0からp_は
すべて正の実数であり、x_0からx_はrowの正規直交固有ベクトルであり、Rはたまたま
行のランクについてだが、ちなみにこの時点でスペクトル定理にいかに頻繁に頼っているか気づいただろうか
これは信じられないほど便利なツールで、実際これなしではどうにもならない。ともかく、スペクトル
分解の行が得られたので、先ほどと同様に2つのベクトルのシュミット分解を計算できる。結果は
ほぼ同じになる。係数とXベクトルは同じだ。なぜなら、それらは縮約状態のスペクトル分解から来ており、
両方のベクトルで同じだからだ。唯一の違いは、第2系のベクトルが異なる場合があることだ。
第1のベクトルであるsについては、y0からy_までのベクトル集合が得られ、第2のベクトルであるfについては、
場合によっては異なる集合が得られ、それをz0からz_と呼べる。これで2つのベクトルのシュミット分解が得られた。
この2つは非常に似ているが、第2系のベクトルが異なる可能性がある。しかし
これらはシュミット分解なので、2つの集合はともに正規直交だ。よって単純に
各aについてy_aをz_aに送るユニタリ行列Uを選べばいい。それは常に可能だ。
ユニタリ演算はある正規直交基底を別の基底に変換する線形写像と同値であり、
この2つの集合がYに対応する空間全体を張らない場合でも、両方を正規直交
基底に拡張できる。偶然にもグラム・シュミット直交化手順を使って。こうしてユニタリ
精製の同値性が証明される。シリーズのレッスン4では超高密度符号化プロトコルについて説明した。
これは送信者が1 ebitの共有エンタングルメントを代償として1つのqubitを送ることで、2つの古典ビットを受信者に伝送できるプロトコルだ。
そのプロトコルはすでに知っているものとして、この例のポイントはそれが
精製のユニタリ同値性とどう結びつくかを簡単に説明することだ。プロトコルの仕組みを思い出してほしい。
AliceとBobがebit、つまりφ⁺ベル状態を共有している。Aliceは送りたい2ビットに応じて、そのベル状態を4つのベル状態のいずれかに変換する。
そしてBobに彼女のqubitを送り、Bobはどのベル状態かを測定して確認する。4つのベル状態すべてが
Bobのqubitに対して同じ縮約状態を与えることに注目してほしい。それは完全混合状態だ。実際、それだけで
超高密度符号化が可能であると結論づけるのに十分だ。4つのベル状態すべてが完全混合状態を精製しているから、精製の
ユニタリ同値性により、Aliceは自分のqubitにユニタリ演算を適用することで、φ⁺ベル状態を他の状態に変換できるはずだとわかる。
もちろん、実際に機能するユニタリ演算を見つけることは難しくなく、非常にシンプルだ。しかし、それでも興味深いのは、
ユニタリ演算自体を考えることなく、これが可能だという結論に達せることだ。さらに、
超高密度符号化をより大きな系に一般化することも可能だと結論づけられる。
ただし、ベル状態をより大きな系に一般化して、すべてがBobの縮約状態として完全混合状態を与えるような方法が必要だ。
実際、そのような方法はいくつか知られている。精製のユニタリ同値性が意味を持つ別の設定は量子
暗号であり、その最も重要な含意の1つは、ビットコミットメントという
暗号プリミティブに対して無条件に安全な量子プロトコルの存在を否定することだ。
ではビットコミットメントとは何か？ビットコミットメントは暗号プリミティブの一例で、
低レベルのタスクや手順のことであり、基本的な機能を提供する。
これはデジタル署名方式の作成やゼロ知識プロトコルの構築など、より興味深いことへの
構成要素として使える。ビットコミットメントの場合、基本的な機能は
プレイヤーAliceが選んだ二値をもう一方のプレイヤーBobにコミットできるが、彼女の選択は
開示するまで隠されたままであるということだ。ビットコミットメントを実装するプロトコルには2つの特性が必要だ。
バインディングでなければならない。つまり、Aliceはビットにコミットした後で気が変わることができない。そして
コンシーリングでなければならない。つまり、Aliceが開示するまで、BobはAliceのビットを知ることができない。
このプリミティブを量子情報を使って実装できれば非常に便利だ。
有用なプリミティブだからだ。しかし追加の仮定なしでは、量子情報を使って完全に、あるいは完全に近い形で実装することは不可能だとわかっている。
精製のユニタリ同値性がそれを示している。高レベルでの考え方は、
もし量子ビットコミットメントプロトコルが存在するなら、そのプロトコルのいわゆる精製版が存在しなければならないということだ。Aliceが系Aを持ち、
Bobが系Bを持つと想像できる。コミットメントが行われた後、Aliceが開示する前に、ペアABは
Aliceがコミットするビットに応じて、2つの純粋状態ψ₀またはψ₁のいずれかにある。
プロトコルが完全にコンシーリングであれば、Bobは2つのコミットメントの違いを識別できないはずだ。
つまり、2つの可能性に対してBobの縮約状態は同じでなければならない。しかしそれは
精製のユニタリ同値性により、AliceがAだけにユニタリ演算を適用することでどちらか一方をもう一方に変換できることを意味する。
つまり、プロトコルはバインディングに完全に失敗している。そこには省略した詳細があるが、
問題の核心は、精製のユニタリ同値性がこのプリミティブを
追加の仮定なしに量子情報を使って確実に実装することはできないと示していることだ。
精製のユニタリ同値性の最後の例として、
Houston Joseph Woodersの定理、略してHJW定理として知られる定理がある。
定理の内容から始めよう。いくつかの技術的詳細を避けて本質に集中するため、
少し簡略化したバージョンだ。XとYが系で、Fがペアの純粋状態を表す量子状態ベクトルであるとする。
XYのペアの純粋状態だ。次に、系X単独の縮約状態を考え、任意の方法で
この縮約状態を純粋状態の凸結合として表現することを考える。画面に示されているように。
たとえば、この式の中の大文字Nは平均を取る純粋状態の数で、
任意に大きくなる可能性がある。XやYに対応する空間の次元よりもはるかに大きくなる可能性もある。
定理が示すのは、n個の結果を持つ系Yの測定が存在するはずだということだ。
次のようなことが起きる：系Yが測定されると、まず各測定結果が
Xの縮約状態の表現における対応する確率と正確に等しい確率で出現し、
純粋状態の凸結合であり、第二に特定の測定結果を得ることを条件とすると、
Xの状態は凸結合から対応する純粋状態になる。それがなぜ
面白いかというと、Xの縮約状態を凸結合として考えるどんな方法を選んでも、
Yの何らかの測定が存在して、Xの縮約状態についてのこの考え方を
現実のものにするということだ。そして注目すべきことに、状態fが先に選ばれ、凸
結合が後で選ばれた場合でも、それがXの縮約状態の表現である限り、
このようにうまく機能するYの測定が存在する。では、どうやって証明できるか見てみよう。
Xの縮約に対する2つの異なる表現から始める。これをRowと名付けることにする。
次に、古典状態が可能な測定結果、
すなわち凸結合のインデックスである新しい系Zを導入する。すると、次の2つの量子状態ベクトルが
gamma 0とGamma 1であり、どちらも複合系XYZの状態ベクトルであるが、
どちらもrowの純粋化だとわかる。明確にしておくと、これらのベクトルをrowの純粋化と考えるとき、
系YとZを合わせて1つの複合系として捉え、それをトレースアウトして
Rowが残ると考えている。最初のベクトルgamma 0は、本質的には元の純粋状態5と同じものだが、新しい系Zを
ゼロ状態に初期化している。YとZをトレースアウトするとRowが残ることは明らかなので、gamma
0はrowの純粋化だ。2番目のベクトルGamma 1は、基本的に
授業の前半で述べたように、凸結合に基づいてrowを純粋化して得られるベクトルだ。今度は系Yが
初期化されている。簡単のためにゼロがYの古典状態だと仮定しているが、任意の
標準基底状態、あるいは実際にはYの任意の純粋状態をこの式に代入しても何も変わらない。いずれにせよ、YとZ
を再びトレースアウトするとRowが残る。つまり、これらはどちらもrowの純粋化であり、したがって
純粋化のユニタリ等価性により、gamma 0をGamma 1に変換するペアYZ上のユニタリ演算Uが存在する。
あとはそれだけで、定理が
述べることをする測定の記述を導き出せる。簡単な記述方法は、画面に表示されているようなcircuit図だ。言葉で説明すると、
状態Fから始め、ゼロ状態に初期化されたZを導入し、Uを実行してから、上の系、すなわちZを
標準基底測定で測定する。実質的にこれはfiをGamma Oneに変換するもので、
Gamma 1の記述を見るだけで、これが定理の通り、確率PAで
各結果aを得て、aを得ることを条件に系Xが状態saに残ることがわかる。
明確にしておくと、定理が存在を示唆する測定自体は、
図の点線の長方形内のすべてによって実装されている。そして
測定を行列の集合として記述したい場合、その表現がある。この部分は説明しないし、
例のためには重要ではないが、興味があれば
それが測定行列の表現だ。次に忠実度について議論する。これは2つの量子状態がどれほど似ているか、あるいは
どれほど重なっているかの尺度だ。定義から始めるが、最初は少し謎めいて見えるかもしれない。
しかし解きほぐしていけば、議論の終わりには、最初の印象より
実はずっと良い関数だと納得してもらえると思う。その
定義はこうだ。2つの密度行列RowとSigmaの間の忠実度は、
Rowの平方根 * Sigma * Rowの平方根の平方根のトレースに等しい。
まず定義自体を理解しようとしよう。3つの平方根があり、
それらはすべて半正定値行列の平方根を指している。前の授業で議論したように、これは
平方根を取っている行列を得るために二乗する、一意な半正定値行列だ。
Rowは密度行列なので半正定値でなければならず、その平方根が取れる。Rowの平方根 *
Sigma * Rowの平方根について考えると、これも半正定値であり、特に
SigmaのSigmaの平方根 * Rowの平方根をMとすると、M†*Mと書けるため、その平方根が取れる。
特に、Rowの平方根 *
Sigma * Rowの平方根のスペクトル分解を計算でき、平方根を取るには固有
値の平方根を取り、固有ベクトルはそのままにすればよい。最後にこの
行列のトレースを取る。トレースは固有値の和に等しいので、右に示す表現が得られる。
一般的にはこれを手計算したくないだろうし、この説明は忠実度や
それを使う理由についてあまり洞察を与えないかもしれないが、公式の技術的な
意味を明確にしてくれるといいな。ちなみに余談として、忠実度を
ここで定義した関数の二乗として定義し、この関数を「ルート
忠実度」と呼ぶ人もいる。どちらの方法でも定義されるのを見るが、混乱の原因になりうるものの、通常はそうならない。
なぜなら、どちらの定義を使っているか明確にすることに人々が概してかなり注意しているからだ。
君も同じようにすべきだ。私の目には、正しい定義も間違った定義も本当にない。私がこのように定義するのは
単純にこのやり方に慣れているからで、後で必要が生じたときに平方根を取るよりも二乗する方が少し便利だと感じるからだが、
もちろん自分で好きな方を選んでいい。
ともかく、ここで定義されている忠実度に戻ろう。忠実度を定義する他の等価な方法があり、
その点では実に注目すべき関数で、かなり興味深い方法で特徴付けられる。
前の授業の終盤で見たトレースノルムを使って定義を書き直す、かなり直接的な方法がある。
トレースノルムについてはあまり詳しく説明しなかったし、特に
非エルミート行列に対しては定義すらしなかったが、十分単純な定義がある。トレースノルムを定義する1つの方法は
任意の行列Mのトレースノルムとは、M * Mダガーの平方根のトレース、あるいは同等に
MダガーにMをかけた平方根のトレースのことで、どちらの方法でも同じ値が得られる。その定義を使って
画面下部に示したFidelityの定義を簡略化できる。これは
2つの引数に対して対称であることを示していて便利だ。また、正方行列MのトレースノルムをMとUの積のトレースの絶対値の最大値として表すこともできる。
すべてのユニタリ行列Uにわたる最大値として表せる。これは自明ではないが
正しい。それによってFidelityの別の表現が得られる。つまり、ここに3つの
Fidelityの等価な定義がある。これはほんの始まりで、他にもいくつかの等価な定義があり、
レッスンの終盤でUhlmannの定理から導かれる特に重要なものを見ることになる。
さて、それはわかったとして、直感的なレベルでは何を意味するのか、なぜこの
関数を気にかけるべきなのか。これらの疑問に答えるため、2つの密度行列の少なくとも一方が
純粋状態を表す特殊なケースを考えると便利だ。両方の状態が純粋であれば、
Fidelityは単に2つの量子状態ベクトルの内積の絶対値になる。ある意味で
これはFidelity自体の主な動機だ。2つの量子状態ベクトルの内積の絶対値は
常に0と1の間の数であり、2つの量子状態ベクトルの重なりがどれほどあるかを測る自然な方法を与えてくれる。
Fidelityは、この重なりの測り方を純粋状態から密度行列へと
拡張する有用でよく振る舞いのいい方法だと考えることができる。一方の状態が純粋で
もう一方が必ずしも純粋でない場合も、Fidelityの簡単な表現があって、かなり
便利だ。その表現はここに示されている。Fidelityには多くの興味深い
性質があって、それが人々に使われる理由の一つだ。定義は特に
きれいではないが、それでも非常に有用な関数で、多くの
優れた性質のおかげで使いやすいことが多い。では、いくつかを見ていこう。まず、2つの密度行列間のFidelityは
常に0と1の間の数だ。Fidelityが0になるのは、状態が
直交する場合、つまり像が直交部分空間であること、あるいは同等に2つの行列の積が
ゼロの場合に限られる。Fidelityが1になるのは2つの密度行列が等しい場合に限られる。それ以外は
その間のどこかになる。直感的に言えば、Fidelityが1に近いほど状態はより似ているか、あるいは別の言い方をすれば
より多く重なっている。Fidelityはまた対称でもある。少し前に述べたように、
トレースノルムによるFidelityの表現から明らかだが、認識しておくことは重要だ。
次に、Fidelityは積状態に対して乗法的だ。つまり、2つの
積状態間のFidelityは常に個々の状態間のFidelityの積に等しい。
ここに非常に有用な性質がある。同じサイズの2つの密度行列と、
それらを入力とするチャネルがあれば、そのチャネルを両方の状態に適用するとFidelityは大きくなるだけだ。
つまり言い換えると、Fidelityの観点からは、チャネルは状態を
より似たものにすることしかできない。より異なるものにはできない。最後に、このリストでは、
Fidelityとトレース距離の間にかなり密接な関係がある。トレース距離は
2つの密度行列の差のトレースノルムの半分として定義される。2つの状態間のトレース距離は
どれだけうまく区別できるかに強く関連しており、それは前のレッスンで
状態判別とHelstrom-Holevoの定理の文脈で議論した。一方、Fidelityは2つの状態の重なりを定量化する。
だから、全く同じものではないが、これら2つの量の間に関係があることは驚くことではない。
いずれにせよ、これらの不等式は通常Fuchs-van de Graaf不等式と呼ばれ、
この関係を数学的に精確にしている。また、ここでは系のサイズに全く依存しないことも重要だ。
この関係は図の助けを借りると少し明確に見える。2つの状態があって、
それらのトレース距離をx軸に、Fidelityをy軸に配置すると、対応する縦線と
横線はこの灰色の領域のどこかで交わらなければならない。最も興味深い領域は
ところで、少なくとも実用的な観点からは、灰色の領域の左上隅だ。特にトレース距離が
非常に小さい場合、Fidelityは1に非常に近くなければならず、逆も然りだ。
これらの不等式は非常に頻繁に使われる。その理由の一部は、最終的には
トレース距離の方をより気にかけることが多いからで、それは量子状態判別と結びついた自然な解釈があるからだ。
しかしFidelityには素晴らしい性質がたくさんあるので、一般的に扱いやすく、灰色の領域の左上隅にいる限り、
よくある状況だが、FidelityとトレースReaderを行き来してもあまり損はない。というわけで、
これらはFidelityの性質のいくつかだ。もっとたくさんあるが、良い出発点であり、
Fidelityについての直感を養い始めるのに役立つリストだと思う。ここにFidelityを
非破壊測定と結びつける良い例がある。Gentle Measurement
Lemmaとして知られる非常に便利な事実だ。系Xと、密度行列ρで表されるXの状態と、系X上の測定があるとする。
測定は正半定値行列の集まりで記述される。測定の結果の一つが状態ρに対して測定を行うと非常に
高い確率で現れると仮定しよう。簡単のため、
非常に確率が高いのは結果ZZだとしよう。特に、この結果が
1マイナスεより大きい確率で現れると仮定する。εの具体的な値は指定しなくていい。
εは単なる小さな正の実数だ。さて、測定を破壊的な測定として記述したが、
前のレッスンから、この測定を非破壊的な方法で実装できることはわかっている。特に
Naimarkの定理の議論で見たようにできる。それはこのように機能する。各結果aは
PA * ρのトレースに等しい確率で現れ、その結果を得た条件付きでXの状態は変化する。
特に確率ゼロという可能性の高い測定結果が得られた場合、状態はp0のルートにrowをかけてp0のルートをかけたものになる
すべて正規化して密度行列が得られる。そして穏やかな測定の極限が教えてくれるのは、このイベントにおいて
つまり確率の高い測定結果が実際に得られた場合、得られる状態は元の状態から
あまり変化していないということだ。特に忠実度の二乗は必ず1マイナス
イプシロンより大きくなる。これは素晴らしいことだ。なぜなら完全に一般的であり、測定については何も
状態については何も言っていない。ただある結果が非常に起こりやすいというだけだ。だからこの補題は
量子状態についてあまり乱さずに何かを検証したい様々な場面で適用できる。では証明の方法を見ていこう
大部分において、これは実際には測定前後の状態の忠実度を計算するだけの比較的単純な話だ
これは元の定義を使って行える。通常は面倒な式になる可能性があるが
今回は運がいい。外側の平方根の中身が実は
半正定値行列の二乗になっているからだ。これにより平方根の計算が自明になる。これでtraceの巡回
性とtraceの線形性を使って式を簡略化できる。画面に示されているように、なおこれらはすべて
等式であることに注意してほしい。この時点では何も近似していない。本当に単純化しているだけだ。しかし次に不等式が必要になる
分子の平方根を取り除きたいからだ。下界で妥協するなら確かにそれが可能だ。もし
この部分の詳細に興味があれば、pのスペクトル分解を考えることで不等式をかなり簡単に得られる
p0の固有値は0と1の間になければならない。これは状態を記述する行列について常に成り立つ
測定であり、それがわかれば、0と1の間の数の平方根を取ると
値が大きくなるという事実から不等式がほぼ直接導かれる。別の言い方をすれば、0と1の間の数を
二乗すると値が小さくなる。ここでもう少し簡略化すると、
p0にrowをかけたtraceの平方根が得られる。最後に両辺を二乗して
確率の下界を代入すると求めるものが得られる。忠実度の公式は
世界で最も扱いやすい公式というわけではないが、ここでは実際かなり
うまく機能する。レッスンの締めくくりとして、Uhlmann（ウールマン）の定理を見ていく。これは忠実度に関する基本的な事実で
浄化の概念と結びついている。定理が簡単な言葉で言っているのは、任意の2つの
量子状態の間の忠実度は、それらの状態の2つの浄化の間の内積の絶対値の最大値に等しいということだ
もう少し詳しく言うと、rowとsigmaがあるシステムXの密度行列であり、Yが
Xと少なくとも同じ数の古典状態を持つシステムであると仮定する。そうすれば、これらの状態の両方が浄化を持つことが保証される
XYの量子状態ベクトルとして。定理の含意を
画面に示された方程式の形で表せる。rowとsigmaの間の忠実度はfiとSの内積の
絶対値の最大値に等しい。ここでfiとSはrowとsigmaを浄化するすべての
ものについての範囲をとる。整理して正確な数学的記述で進めよう。今から定理を証明するが
まず忠実度についての直感的な考え方を提供してくれるということを少し評価する時間を取る価値がある
忠実度についてのさらに興味深い事実を証明するためなどにも、それ自体かなり有用だ
忠実度についてそれを証明するため、密度行列のスペクトル分解から始める
特に驚くべきことではない。スペクトル分解が得られれば、
これらの状態の2つの具体的な浄化を簡単に見つけられる。しかしここで実際に
トリックを使う。両方の場合において、以前のレッスンでやったような第二テンソル因子として標準基底ベクトルを
使っていないことに気付く。むしろ第一テンソル因子と同じベクトルを使うが、そのベクトルにはバーが付いており
つまりこれらのベクトルの成分ごとの複素共役を意味する。言い換えると基本的には
固有ベクトルの第二コピーをとるが、各成分の複素共役をとる。なぜそうするのかは少し後でわかる
なぜそうすべきかは全く明らかではない。だからこそトリックと呼ぶ
いずれにせよ、これらはrowとsigmaそれぞれの浄化だ。それは
固有ベクトルが正規直交であり、したがって成分ごとの複素共役もそうであるという事実による。ここで浄化の
ユニタリ同値性を適用できる。2つの状態のすべての浄化は、トレースアウトされるシステムに
ユニタリ演算を適用することで得られると言っている。先ほど選んだ具体的な浄化に対して
2つの浄化でユニタリ演算が同じである必要はない
もちろんそうだ。だから1つ目にはUという文字を、2つ目にはVという文字を使う
つまり要点は、2つの状態のすべての浄化が画面に示されているように書けるということだ
あるユニタリ演算uとvの選択に対して。これで定理からの式を
取り込んで簡略化できる。fiとSの式を代入して少し簡略化すると
画面に示されている式が得られる。いくつかのステップがあり詳細は示していない
もしやりたければ何をすべきかわかる。ただ、なぜあのように浄化を選んだかを述べておくと
この内積がまさにこのように簡略化されるようにするためだ。特に複素共役を
入れることで、第二テンソル因子の内積を効果的に反転させて特定の
形を得ることができた。もう少しで完了だ。traceの巡回性を使い
始めたスペクトル分解とともにこの式を得る。この時点で
traceノルムを使って忠実度を表す代替方法の1つを利用でき
証明完了だ。確かに私が非常にざっくりと飛ばした詳細がいくつかある。完全に理解するためには
自分で実際に証明を追う必要がある。しかしこれが基本的な
アイデアを伝えられれば幸いだ。いつものように、ビデオの
説明にリンクされているレッスンの書面コンテンツに詳細がある。これでレッスンの終わりだ。浄化、忠実度、そしてそれらの間の関係についてのレッスンで、また
量子情報の一般的な定式化についてのユニットの終わりに来た。次も一緒に見てほしい、
このシリーズの第4回、最終ユニットは量子誤り訂正についてだ。見てくれてありがとう